did they say this thing about me because
i'm black
and it could be not that at all but the
paranoia lingers there
and and the same as
am i being followed around you know
in this store because i'm young or is it
because i'm black am i
not being served because this or because
i'm black or
and and people now want to shut down
those those narratives or those notions
and just say
it's not about your race i quit talking
about your race if you stop talking
about it
it won't be an issue and they don't get
the paranoia you don't like that
you don't want that you wish it wasn't
there
i don't want to go into a store and feel
like my race is the one thing people see
i hate
like it's annoying and now i make sure
that if something happens i make sure
i actually think about it before i react
for me mostly um but before
what you're feeling in that park is what
black americans feel
all the time and we're not exaggerating
where
if someone's like oh you're very
articulate yeah that i am going to think
youth
and i will the whole script paragraph
you think i'm articulate because you
think black people are stupid therefore
you're shocked that i can say a sentence
like that it's just very and
it's annoying and
the thing is is like sometimes
you know you or someone else that might
feel
like oh i want to interact with this
black family or whoever
it might feel like a tension of don't
come over here
it might actually be more of us feeling
like
we're not a danger to you so
it's a mixed signal thing everyone's on
edge
but if someone could really
rewind and listen to what you said
that is exactly what it feels like when
you feel people have a problem with your
skin and they don't know you and you're
like
is it because of that though and just
that paranoia is like a bug you're
so annoyed all the time you're like when
will this stop i
want a world in which effectively
it is you know everybody is aware of the
same thing right i don't know if this is
exactly fair you can help me
correct it if it's not but my sense is
that there's a gray area but that by and
large
a black person knows when they're
dealing with somebody
who's got an issue they may not know
exactly what the issue is but you can
detect it
right there's something hidden you know
i deal with this a little bit being
jewish they're people who
have some kind of suspicion about what
that is it's pretty rare that i
encounter it but i do encounter it
and then there are people who have some
very superficial
you know they'll like recognize that my
name is jewish or that i
look jewish and you know
i have the sense that you know it is
noted and then
in interacting it doesn't typically end
up being an important fact and it
dissipates
but my sense is that you probably in
general know
whether or not somebody has an issue
that's unstated
or whether somebody really doesn't have
an issue and then there's probably some
gray area where you don't know for sure
is that fair definitely okay and when
there is gray
i i like you say make might take notes
but i don't create it into something i
kind of just let
it be perfect so imagine that the
well-intentioned white folk knew
that this was kind of the rubric right
that when you meet black people
if you've got a real issue they'll know
it if you don't have a real issue
they'll figure it out and if you're a
little bit uncomfortable that might get
noted but it's not
you know it still leaves room to
discover that you're cool and that you
have
you know cool stuff to interact about
you have shared interests or whatever
if people knew that and the point was
okay
most of us in fact i will tell you i
think the thing that i
know that you can't know is what gets
said when you're not in the room
right so i know what those conversations
about i don't want to know
you do no i do in general you do because
in general it's not what you fear
right that i i never hear that
conversation or
almost never right um you know so anyway
i'm in a position that
to help you calibrate because i mean
this whole you know you mentioned the
question of uh using the word articulate
with
a black person this is now a problem for
white people
like me who use the word articulate
because it's something i value and i
would use it for anybody who is
articulate and now there's this very
difficult calculation which is
okay i'm pretty sure there's something
wrong with the fact that i think being
articulate is good
and if somebody is black and articulate
i can't use that word right that's a
problem
right but i get why it's i get why this
is an issue i get that it is used by
whites and it
has this coded level to it but it
doesn't mean that everybody who uses it
uses it that way and yet
even though i don't think i have a
problem with this i now don't know what
to do with that word
right it is allowed for certain people
and not others
yes it's sad that that's a word that's
taboo
but there's a lot of historical context
with that i will say
just examples of that with my american
shade podcast
um a lot of people come on and
and i get these comments all the time um
let's just say i might have a bandana on
in one of my
videos and that's all they see in the
thumbnail and
then they click and they hear me talk
and then the comment is like
i'm going to be honest with myself in
public announce this i thought you were
going to be the typical woke like thug
um yo yo yo like i'm not kidding
like they will say this but they're like
but you're a very intelligent
articulate young wise woman
and blah blah blah thinking that i'm
going to like the comment
like it's i i understand
that they're trying to be open so i
don't delete these things though i'm not
like silly no i let them be
because i'm like those are the moments
where like i
just really like try to pull in my
christianity as much as i can
i'm like you know what they're human
being vulnerable
and there's even though this is very
ignorant
my channel is about these conversations
and they are telling me
explicitly what they thought of me and
now they don't
so at the end of the day is this
something it is bad
right but it's something that changed
their perception so maybe next time when
they see
a group of kids with bandanas maybe
they won't have the initial reaction
that these are thugs
maybe maybe that will help but i get
these all the time and then when you
hear
um you know especially with obama yes he
was articulate
but when you just hear like this
president was this this this and they
just
are you know but then when it was with
obama who were like
wow like he can speak clear
yeah that's gonna be annoying we're
gonna be like well why is
this one president the articulate one
i mean weren't they all or is it
expected for the rest of them to be
and this one wasn't well if i can if i
can just say for my part
i should say i have mixed emotions about
obama i voted for him once i didn't vote
for him twice
and uh the problem is i actually really
interpersonally i like him i think he's
a very likable guy and i did find him
extraordinary as a speaker like he stood
out right
he was really really good um it was at a
policy level and i still don't know why
he i thought he was a mess at a policy
level and you know it's possible that he
couldn't do better but there were some
things i just can't explain that way but
never mind that i think i think the
problem is that in his case
um he he'd be unusual
in any configuration he's of
i don't know what exactly explains him
unusual
developmental history that
you know a very singular human
and so anyway the problem is that in
describing
such a singular human who happens to be
singular as a president
in this particular way also right our
first black president
um these things get tangled up because
you're no matter what you're doing
you're describing you know a
one in seven billion phenomenon right no
matter what
yeah and so anyway i don't know what to
do with it exactly but the problem is
at some level let's just both agree
you and i have both encountered a
problem with the word uh articulate
the problem with the word articulate
that we have is inverse you don't know
what people are really implying when
they say it and i don't know how to use
it anymore because i know
that that's a hazard that it's like a
word that now has
all of this potential energy built up in
it and even
if i'm perfectly even-handed in how i
use it and basically i just use it
anytime
somebody speaks in a way that impresses
me
there's no way any individual could know
that right
so you can't know if it's charged right
um
so what we need at some level i'm
certain
is enough interaction
that we're not dealing from these
anecdotes
and the problem for me
i tweeted about this earlier this week i
tweeted
segregation causes racism
and i don't mean that the opposite isn't
also true because i believe the opposite
is clearly true
um but i think the problem is
much of the what passes for
sophistication in
these social justice circles is the idea
that what we need to do
is group by skin color right
and while i know that there is
the need to be able to do that sometimes
right that
you know it makes perfect sense that if
a group of people is facing
a phenomenon they might need to talk
about it amongst themselves right so
the right to gather in such groups is
is important and it's a fundamental
right
but the need to always gather in those
groups is causing us to know less and
less about each other
and i i i feel like that's
utterly counterproductive that it is
going to create racism where actually
racism was getting better
i now feel like in the last couple of
years it's getting worse and part of the
problem is
that it is getting harder to have a
casual interaction that might actually
allow you to understand more
yes i i agree with that and i think
just the shorter answer is there's just
a big trust issue
it's just a big trust issue and it's not
with every single
american or black american but
like you said when you're walking that
park you don't know if that person has
that trust issue
with you or not and it's better maybe
it's just better i walk around them
and don't interact um which then creates
more of a trust issue
exactly because if you don't just do it
you'll never know but
um then there are organizations that
really
have a trust issue with with white
people coming in because they don't know
if they have good intentions
they don't know if they can trust them
they they don't know if they're actually
another organization trying to
infiltrate them or trying to like
you know co-opt or whatever they they
don't know so they're like well it's
better that we just keep it
all black because at least we know
that everyone in here is for this cause
and better safe than sorry i think
people rather just be
better safe than sorry now um
[Music]
for me there are definitely times where
you have to be it's better to be safe
than sorry
but with conversations now i will have
conversations with anyone
and i'll be cautious but i'd rather be
like dang
that didn't go the way i wanted it to go
like i'd rather that
than never talking to someone that
i might feel might not be receptive to
me or whatever but
yeah i think at the end of the day it's
a trust issue um and i don't know
how that is tackled other than people
just coming out of their comfort zones
[Music]
you